الى خبر يبعث للامل القاتل الذي لطالم بث
الخوف في قلوب الملايين للعقود قد يكون
شارف على الانحسار فالخبراء بحسب الدين
البريطانيه يقولون ان مرض السرطان يتحول
ببطء الى حاله يمكن السيطره عليها
فمقارنه بتشخيط في السبعينات تضاعفت
معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه لمده عشر
سنوات لبعض انواع السرطان
يتوقعوا الاطباء ان معدلات البقاء على قيد
الحياه عند الاصابه بالسرطان قد تكون
مضاعفه بشكل اكبر خلال عقد من السماء بحسب
خبراء من معهد ابحاث السرطان فان التقنيات
المتطوره على وجهك احداث ثوره في رعايه
مرضى السرطان الى الابد مع امكانيه اجراء
مزيد من التحصينات في العقد هذا الاتجاه
الواحد يرجع الى مجموعه من العوامل تشمل
علاجات اكثر فاعليات مكتشفها لعلاج
الامراض وتشخيصات افضل لتحديد وتعقب
السرطان في الجسم ونجاح تثقيف الجمهور حول
اعراض المعكره
معدلات النجاه من مرض السرطان وصلت الى
قفزه كبيره في الخمسين عاما الماضيه وتوقع
الباحثون في مركز الدولي لابحاث السرطان
بجراه ان بعض انواع السرطان تنقرض في
السنوات القادمه بالنظر الى جميع انواع
السرطان يتوقع ان ترتفع معدلات الشفاء الى
60 بالمئه في العقد المقبل قبل ان ترتفع
الى 80% في عام 2045 احد جوانب الرئيسيه
لتحسين معادلات النجوم من السرطان بحسب
الخبراء هو التشخيص السريع فاذا كنت تريد
الحفاظ على معدل شفاء مرتفع فمن المهم حقا
تجلس السرطان في اقرب وقت ممكن بالنسبه
لبعض انواع السرطان من المتوقع بالفعل ان
ينجو اكثر من تسعه من عشره من عشره من كل
عشره اشخاص من المرهم وهذا يشمل سرطان
الجلد عند النساء وسرطان الخصيه اما سرطان
الثدي والغده الدرقيه تزيد نسبه البقاء
على قيد الحياه عن 70% ويمكن ان يؤدي
لاكتشاف المبكر الى تحسين هذه النسبه
السرطان عنق الرحم يمكن ان ينقر التقريبا
بفضل نجاح برنامج لقاح فيروز الورى من
حليم البشري الا ان معدلات البقاء على قيد
الحياه على المدى الطويل لبعض اشكال المرض
مثل سرطان الرئه والبنكرياس لا تزال اقل
من 10%
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم الينا اخصائي اورام معالج
بالاشعه الدكتور رامي زي ابو حجه دكتوره
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك انا جيت من السرطان
تتضاعف في غضون 10 سنوات هل بالفعل نحن
امام نهايه الطريق في محاربه المرض القاتل
القريبه
صباح الخير صباح الخير لك
جميع
المشاهدين على قناه العربيه الحمد لله
اخبار طبعا جيده النسب الشفاء تتضاعف في
عده سرطانات على راسها سرطان الثدي وسرطان
البروستات نسبه الشفاء في سرطان الثدي على
سبيل المثال ارتفعت من حوالي 40 الى 80%
وعندنا سرطان البروستات ارتفعت حوالي ثلاث
اضعاف من حوالي 25 الى اكثر من 75% كلمه
السر هنا زي ما ذكرته في تقريركم هو
التوعيه والكشف المبكر من 50 سنه زي ما
حكيته كلمه سرطان هي كلمه مرعبه او مخيفه
وبالتالي الناس كانت تخاف من من هذا المرض
وتربطه دائما بالوفاه الان صار في عندنا
جلسات واا دورات تثقيفيه كثيره وتوعويه في
هذا المرض الناس صارت تدرك انه الكشف
المبكر لهذا المرض يساعد في نسب الشفاء
يعني على سبيل المثال سرطان البروستات لما
نحكي نسبه الشفاء وصلت الان همم 80% احنا
بنحكي على كل مراحل المرض بينما المرحله
المبكره من المرض يصل الشفاء فيها حتى 95%
فبالتالي كل ما كان الكشف مبكر تكون شفاء
افضل طيب
دكتور هناك
من مرض السرطان ونحن في مسار حياه غير
صحيه بامتياز على كل النواحي ومن سيئ الى
اسوا
طبعا سؤال مهم للاسف
نمط الحياه تبعنا الي صار كل يعني يتحول
للاسوء خلينا نحكي على سبيل المثال الغذاء
نبدا فيه الغذاء صرنا ناخذ اكثر الدهون
الدهون المشبعه والغذاء المصنع والمواد
الحافظه فهذا كل مختلف عن الاغذيه كلنا
نتناولها السابق بالاضافه لتعرضنا للاشعه
واهم اهم عامل الان موجوده والتدخين للاسف
التدخين اصبح مشكله كبيره في المجتمعاتنا
العربيه مثال عندنا الاردن لبنان مصر وحتى
في الخليج للاسف يعتبر الان وباء موجود
ولكن في المقابله زي ما ذكرنا صار في
عندنا توعيه كشف مبكر للاعراض المبكره
فالناس اصبحت تيجي للطبيب في اعراض مبكر
اول ما يبدا المرض وبلا شك في تحسن كبير
حصل على مستوى العلاجات المتاحه يعني زمان
يعني على راسها الرنين المغناطيسي
تقول انه التقنيه الحديثه على عتاب احداث
ثوره 100 في مجال مكافحه هذا المرض القاتل
السرطان اليوم عندما نتحدث عن تقنيات
حديثه نتحدث عن العلاج بالاشعاع في
السرطان يعني ما ابرز هذه التقنيات
المنتظره التي يمكن ان تحدث خرق علمي في
هذا الاطار
الصحيح التخصص الاشعه على سبيل المثال في
السابق كانت التقنيات الشيعيه والاجهزه
اللي بتعطي العلاج الشعاعي خليني احكي
قديمه او ما بتعطي الاشعه بتركيز كافي
فبالتالي المضاعفات بتنشا منها كبيره وما
بنقدر نعطي كميات كبيره من العلاج الشعاعي
الموجه الان بفضل هاي التقنيات صرنا مش بس
حتى المراحل المبكره حتى المراحل المتاخره
نقدر نصوب شغله بنسميها الجراحات الشعاعيه
على اماكن انتشار المرض ونسيطر عليها فهي
حتى صارت تعطي امل للسيطر على المرض حتى
مع المراحل المتقدمه في ال- همم في همم في
علاج السرطان وكمان ما ننسى قبل المجالات
الاخرى زي الجراحه تحسنت انتقلنا من
جراحات اللابر وسكوب او الجراحات المنظار
الى جراحات الروبوت المتوفر عندنا في
المستشفى بالاضافه في العلاجات الاخرى
كالعلاجات المناعيه همم برده عملت ثوره
عندنا في علاج السرطان
همم يعني وعلى فكره حتى بس دكتور رامز هيك
اضافه انه 98% من سرطان الثدي تم معالجته
لانه يتم تشخيصه مبكر وكمان زاد الوعي
بالنسبه للنساء زاد الوعي باهميه الفحص
المبكر فقط هذا مداخله يعني
بالضبط عشان هيك بحب اشكركم يعني احنا
الشهر اللي فات كان عنا بشهر 10 اللي هو
امراض التوعيه بامراض الثدي او سرطان
الثدي امراض الذكوره اللي هي على راسها
الرئه والبروستات
الشكر دكتور رامز